Leslie I typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
[Music]
location I will be conducting a security
sweep also from now on we'll be using
code names you can address me as Eagle
One and code name been there done that
April is currently doing that Donna is
it happened once in a dream Chris
codename if I had to pick a dude Ben is
Eagle two oh thank God
I can't believe we're at Hogwarts no
that's Buckingham Palace
Hogwarts is fictional do you know that
it's important to me that you know that
Andy are you okay oh I'm fine it's just
that life is pointless and nothing
matters and I'm always tired also I
can't sleep I'm overeating none of my
old Hobby's interest me
ever since Andy failed the police
academy exam his self-esteem has hit
rock bottom he's always sad and sweaty
he's usually happy and sweaty
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster I had to also I had a
banana on the way over here
sorry I get why you don't want anyone to
know about Duke silver and you don't
have to worry
your secret is safe with me
to even it out I'm going to tell you all
of my secrets oh no that's not necessary
I once forgot to brush my teeth for five
weeks I didn't actually sell my last car
I just forgot where I parked it I don't
know who Al Gore is and at this point
I'm too afraid to ask when they say two
percent milk I don't know what the other
98 is when I was a baby my head was so
big scientist it experiments on me I
once threw beer at a swan and then it
attacked my niece Rebecca that'll do
Andrew
go go go
go yes oh my God that's so hot it was
horrible
I'm going to die I'm so tired
everything hurts running is impossible
oh
what are you doing Tom now is not the
time for criticism how did he do and he
finishes two mile run in 29 minutes and
43 seconds no I'm never gonna be a cop
I'm gonna have to be a robber so the
only thing you did was stop drinking
beer yeah I lost 50 pounds in one month
how much beer were you drinking I know
right probably too much
did you hit your head no
oh yes technically I did Smash my head
area into the wall area yeah he was
hanging up his gold record
oh my God are you okay
I'm good
point is
I have a gold record e h 4 M potato
shape
coffee mug shaped smudge smudge middle
finger smudge the rest are all smudges
oh my God you drove us here we made like
a hundred million doctors appointments
for ourselves in one week after this we
won't have to go to the doctor for like
10 years
because we're smart
well you definitely need glasses no he's
not getting glasses I like his face the
way it is if you get glasses I'll
divorce you well you heard her doc too
handsome for glasses no offense
here's your bill
eating that I've got the free medicine
card uh there's a 500 deductible for
dental procedures oh I think uh you're
wrong we have the insurance thing I
believe we're covered it's still 500.
oh because
you know what let's go Diamond Dash out
of the way
a different ambulance the one I ran into
I've been staring at this board for days
so close to putting it together there's
got to be something we missed let's go
over this again
the video shows that the pie came from a
high angle
so it would have hit your face
like this
mm-hmm
Don't Close Your Eyes
no no it actually was from up higher
is that about right yeah good clean
yourself up let's do this again so I
made my desk out of silver M M's but
they do not make silver m m I spray
painted them okay those are poisonous so
no one eat them yeah duh
go throw up I didn't need any go throw
up
[Music]
what should we do tonight I don't know
let's figure we'll just order some pizza
you watch me play Xbox and then I can
watch you make some prank phone calls we
get hammered make out we do that every
night because repetition is the key to a
good marriage
let's do something weird come on it
could be the last night on earth we
could do something off my bucket list
you have a bucket list catch winning
touchdown at the Super Bowl make the
most amazing grilled cheese sandwich
ever win the lottery ride a unicycle
invent something I'd like to remake the
movie Kazam with Shaquille O'Neal where
he plays a genie and I'd like to get it
right go skydiving outrun a hippo all
right well this is what we're doing
tonight which one this one
800 900 1000. and how much is left in
the bank account
18 and four cents whoa still a lot left
over okay you wanted to hold a thousand
dollars cash in your hands
that's super disappointing
998 999 1
000.
yes now this is what I imagined
have you ever seen this much cash in
your entire life I just handed it to you
Nichols
I want nickels a billion nickels no Andy
um
[Music]
foreign
I could have ever even imagined
yeah
trying to find a way to be annoyed by it
but
coming up empty
thank you so much
I never would have ever done this
without you
thank you
where's all the faces
the president's
it's 5 000 times better than a Candle in
the Wind
This song is called 5 000 candles in the
Wind
[Music]
thing
you trade your legs for
angels and wings
and once we've all said get back
you take a running leap and you learn to
fly
[Music]
bye bye little Sebastian
miss you in the size
[Music]
your 5 000 candles in the Wind
[Applause]